hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast identifying genes related
to you or specific for a disease of
interest presented by Philip Zimmermann
PhD u CH the CEO of nebby on AG in suruc
switzerland i am kristen present a la
Bruce and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth labyrinth of the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble or seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming dr. Philip
Zimmerman I will now turn the
presentation over to him
well hello everyone it's a pleasure for
me to be here at lab ribs today it's the
first time I am giving a presentation
and I'm really excited to be here with
lab roots to talk to you with about the
topic of identifying genes related to or
specific for a disease of interest so
let's get started immediately with the
topic of differential expression so as a
scientist you may have to do gene
expression experiments where you compare
a treatment and control and typically
you would either have your own
experiment or you choose one from gene
educator and you define the treatment
groups and the control group and then
you can run a differential expression
analysis you can do different types of
differential expression analysis like
disease versus healthy or a treatment
against untreated or a time point a
versus a time point B or you may compare
different doses inside an experiment
etcetera now in your particular case you
will be working on one scenario let's
call it the lean number nine in this
example and you will look for genes that
are up or downregulated
in that disease as compared to healthy
tissues so what you will get in such an
analogous analysis is a list of genes
that are upregulated or downregulated in
your particular disease now what you
don't know if you do this analysis on
its own is what do these genes that you
have found do in other diseases you
don't take this into account because
they are not part of your analysis but
let's assume you would know what happens
to these genes in all of these other
conditions then you would find something
like this where
change that in your experiment are very
strongly regulated power sometimes very
specific for your disease for example
the third one here where we see no
regulation in any of the other diseases
but it is regulated in Georgia needs of
interest but you will also get lots of
other genes that are regulated either up
or down in other diseases that you may
not have been aware of if you have never
looked at the data set at the same time
so assuming you would have this
possibility to align other studies other
diseases together with your disease of
interest you could see these effects and
then you could start working on changing
the order of your results such as to
find genes that are really specific for
your disease of interest as you can see
here we have taken the same plot as here
but we have simply ranked those genes
down that are also regulated in all
kinds of other conditions and we keep
those that are specific for the disease
and so what you end up with is a list of
genes that is specifically regulated in
your disease as opposed to simply being
regulated in your disease as compared to
the control when it's analyzed on its
own so what does it need to do this type
of analysis so traditional way of doing
differential expression analysis is you
have your experiment you compare
treatment to control or disease versus
Elfi you get a list of genes and then
you interpret it in some way or the
other and the interpretation of this
list is always that these genes are
somehow related to your disease
unfortunately many scientists interpret
it as being these are the disease
specific genes but as we have just
looked at before they are actually not
really specific for the disease they are
only in some way related to the disease
or they are
a respond and an effect of the disease
but there may not necessarily be
specific so if we want them to be able
to find the genes that are really
specific we need to include all the
other diseases as well so then we are
working on the level of analyzing
thousands of experiments and we can run
different types of analysis on it on a
competitive wide level and also we can
interpret them on that level rather than
interpreting one single study now in
order to have all of these other
diseases combined with our disease of
interest we need to integrate all these
experiments so what we do in our lab
here is to curate public expression data
that we collect from different sources
like gene expression omnibus European
phenomenon archives array Express Cancer
Genome Atlas and many more but as you
may know the datasets although they are
available which is a really great thing
for our research community they are not
fully standardized between the different
repositories but also they are available
in different formats in different
quality there is a big fit orogeny key
and so we have a team of curators who
work on collecting these experiments on
integrating them into the database
curating all the annotations which means
all the descriptions of all of these
samples and then we bring it all
together into a database where
everything is completely systematically
annotated described but also quality
controlled and normalized in a way that
we can compare between experiments so
once this is done you have the
possibilities to run new types of
analysis that you would not be able to
do on one single experiment and in our
particular case
have developed two tools to do that it's
one is protein investigator and the
other is koji invisible which is a
completely free online tool which also
runs on mobile devices and it allows you
to take advantage of all these thousands
of studies to learn more about your
genes of interest or to find genes that
are specific for a disease as we are
looking at in our particular case now
just to give some detail about the
curation process which is really
important for us so the first thing we
do is to control the quality of the data
which means the statistical quality with
detective duplications that can happen
in multiple studies for example you have
a set of reference samples that is used
in two different studies but they are
the same samples so we can identify such
duplications we check the design of the
experiment
and then we read the publications and
verify if we have the same design and
also we get information about every
sample so that we can annotate and
describe them well we use occasionally
also markers to verify some annotations
and of course an important part of it is
to make sure that the work done by one
curator is peer reviewed by another
curator so that we have we can avoid
errors that can be caused by human
intervention and the second level is on
the level of the metadata so all these
samples need to be described properly so
we need to provoke a bellary's that
describe them using the same words and
we do that on the level of the
experiment on the level of the sample
and also on the level of the comparisons
so the curators manually based on
experimental design can define groups of
treatment to control or disease versus
healthy and they had
that into the database we also add
patient characteristics and the mappings
of the different replicas into single
nodes that have particular properties so
it's quite an intensive work to curate
all of this data but at the end once
everything is available in such a
systematic such a clean in such a
high-quality state you can start doing
analysis types that you would not be
otherwise able to do so there are three
levels of data analysis that you can do
with such a high quality compendium the
first level is to pick one experiment
out of the database and to simply run
the type of analysis that you would
traditionally do also on your own
experiment for example differential
expression analysis the second type is
rather new this is where we have
specialized our tools on it's called
platform level so there we allow to
assemble tens or hundreds or thousands
even of studies into one big data matrix
and to be able to run queries like which
genes are specifically expressed in one
disease but not in any of the other
diseases or respond to a particular drug
and not to the other drugs or to a group
of drugs that have the same mode of
action or whatever so you can you can
start identifying genes in a much more
specific way then if you do them
individually on each experiment and you
start to compare so I will show you an
example afterwards what is the
difference between doing meta-analysis
on individual experiments and doing a
global search across all the data at the
same time to find genes that are
specific and then there is a third level
which we will not look at today but it's
about assembling results and not any
more measurement data between different
studies that you have assembled and this
approach is very
because it does not have to go by
platform not even by datatype you can
actually bring together anything
together that says a list of genes and
you can run enrichment good so let's
have a look at one example where we will
try to understand what's the difference
between running differential expression
analysis on individual studies and
running a global search to see which
genes are specific for the disease so
we're going to look at Crohn's disease
it's an inflammatory inflammatory
disorder that is present at about three
per mil in a population and there are
35,000 deaths annually due to this
disease it's a disease that is currently
incurable so we maintain it in remission
essentially and prevent relapse so in
this example here what we are going to
do is to compare the leaf samples versus
versus healthy samples of kuala lumpur
tissues and this comparison was found in
four different studies they were
actually more but we randomly chose four
where we knew that where we saw from the
descriptions that they had all of them
had collected colon mucosal tissues from
disease and from healthy adjacent or
healthy patients and allow you to make
such a comparison and see which genes
are regulated in response to the disease
so what we did was to try to have
approximately 200 genes except for the
first one here where we did not get
quite that high but we didn't want to
have a false discovery rate too bad in
that case so we kept it at below zero
point one but otherwise we are between
150 and 200 genes that are regulated and
what you see here are the plots of
differential expression where we kept
only those genes
are upregulated in response to crohn's
disease as compared to the healthy
controls and in the middle here what you
see is a Venn diagram with four four
colors each color representing one plot
and and maybe it's a little bit small to
read it but what is striking here is
that the overlaps between the different
studies is relatively small let's go to
the next slide to see what it is
so from 601 genes that are upregulated
across all of these four studies only
two teens were found to be replicated in
all four of them in three of the four
studies there were 14 genes and in two
of the four studies we found 21 genes
but all the other approximately 560
genes that were found were found to be
regulated in only one of the four study
and this is really surprising because
you would actually expect that if a
study is well done and the sample
services are the same disease on the
same tissue type against the same
healthy controls done on the stereotype
you would expect to have not hundred
percent overlap but maybe 30 40 50
percent overlap and here it's just a few
percent which is close to being a random
overlap between lists of this size now
if we look at the function of these
genes for example we take genes that are
present in 3 or 4 studies this is listed
for 14 means that we have and we
enriched it against plot arrays in this
case we chose reaction pathways you can
see that the pathways that pop up is
being a more significant are related to
the immune system
so obviously the list of genes obtained
has something
with the immune response it's not really
surprising since Crohn's disease is not
immune disease but it may also mean that
the genes that we observe in the
different experiments reflect processes
that happen in cross delete but may also
happen due to other things maybe to the
microbiome maybe to to other diseases
that these patients had but which we are
not aware of so why do so few genes
overlap between the different studies
and this is a phenomenon that we have
observed not only in Crohn's disease but
also in several other diseases where you
compare disease samples versus health
controls so one hypothesis is that the
tissues harvested don't have exact same
cell type composition and the the
evidence for this is what you see in
this plot here on the top left or top
right for plants where we compared the
variance that is caused in the
transcriptome between a tissue and the
average of all tissues on the one hand
and between a given disease and the
healthy controls or a given perturbation
and the corresponding controls
sorry which are down in the lower part
of the plot and what you see here is
that the difference in transcriptome
population is about 10 times higher if
you compare any given tissue against the
average of all tissues then the effect
that you will see if you have a disease
against the healthy controls so
comparing different tissue types you may
have differences in genes being
expressed of two to five thousand genes
whereas between a disease and a healthy
control if it is well done you would
rather have a few hundred genes that are
regulated so the cell type composition
may strongly bias this type of
comparison which means that in different
laboratories they may have
I may have been collecting different
parts of tissue so maybe collecting only
the the superficial part of the mucosa
or maybe going a little bit deeper and
due to that the composition of the the
tissue is different if they have
collected differences also between the
you need and the healthy and they will
especially in that case get also a very
big differences in expression which have
nothing to do with the disease but with
the composition of the tissues so this
could be one explanation but there could
also be other explanations why there are
so big differences between the different
studies so what we try to do here is to
answer the question how can we find
genes that are really specific for a
particular disease and minimally in the
sense that they are strongly regulated
in the target disease that they are
minimally regulated in all other
diseases and conditions so we developed
an algorithm where we score the
everything of the transcriptome in a big
data matrix where we have thousands of
different comparisons of disease versus
healthy but also drug treatments against
controls or genotypes against other
genotypes whatever kind of comparison
that can occur in transcriptomic studies
they are assembled in a big data matrix
and we have the expression values for
all the genes and then we score all the
genes for their specificity of
expression in a chosen target category
of interest for example Crohn's disease
against all the other conditions or if
you are only interested in comparing
with other diseases you compare only
with that section of all these
comparisons so it's a new approach where
you don't work on one individual study
but you assemble thousands of studies
and you work on all of them at the same
time now the reason why this is platform
level is that we need to have a data
matrix where we are measuring
the same jeans in the same way so that
we have comparable measurements so
unfortunately we cannot makes all kinds
of microarrays or in early sequencing
platforms to do that on the one hand but
still if you have a compendium large
enough with several hundred stand
diseases and potentially thousands of
different compounds and conditions you
will have an excellent an excellent
starting point to find genes that are
specific for it for disease so in this
case here we have used the matrix 133
plus 2 studies it's a very popular
platform so there are very many studies
available and we look for genes that are
specifically expressed in Crohn's
disease then we compared the results
that we obtained with the genes that
were found to be regulated in the for
Crohn's disease studies that we had
analyzed previously and what you see
here is the overlap in the right table
the red dots indicate the genes that
were found the 25 genes that were found
to be specifically expressed in Crohn's
disease and the other colors are genes
that were found in the other studies so
in the 12 from the 21 genes that were
present in two of the four studies only
four were among those that were found to
be
Crohn's disease specific by our analysis
from the 14 genes that were present in
three studies four were found in our
list and from the two teen that the
presently no for studies and being
regulated to know for Crohn's disease
studies both of them were found in our
list however what was interesting was
that there were still 15 other genes
which is more than half which were not
found in these overlaps here now this is
another representation of it you can see
the same both bars as we saw before so
the two genes that were found to be
regulated in all four studies when they
are analyzed separately were also found
in our list but from the 14 that were in
three or four studies only four were in
our list and all the others were not in
our list so they were genes that are
somehow responsive in Crohn's disease
samples in three or four studies but
they are not very specific for the
disease they might be genes that are for
example inflammatory but they are
involved also in many other inflammatory
diseases or the immune response genes
that are also involved in other
processes which of course will pop up if
you can if you compare only that disease
versus healthy controls but they will
not be scored well if you screen them
against all the other diseases and if we
look at what I would have seen to a four
study they are even less and in
percentage and of course from the many
many genes that were found to be
regulated in at least one of the four
studies we had 12 of our genes found in
there which represents only 2% of the
entire list now this is a little bit to
illustrate the case of differential
expression in one study versus the
global search so the blue box here
illustrates the section where we have 25
genes found in this party
a gene expression study that was
published in geo from Crohn's disease
versus healthy control and these are the
top 25 genes and what you can see here
is that these genes are very strongly up
regulated in response to Crohn's disease
this is actually what we were screening
for in the differential expression we
see that they are also strongly up
regulated in ulcerative colitis which is
a related disease so it's not really
surprising they are also to a certain
extent regulated in colorectal at
enormous and all of them are very
strongly down regulated in response to
infliximab
which is one of the frequent drugs used
to treat crohn's disease so there is a
clear interaction between the expression
in in response to the drug and
expression in the in the disease itself
so this is a very nice result that we
can see here we see the same results
also in the top 25 genes that were found
in our analysis for where we screen for
genes that are only or maximally
expressed in Crohn's disease and
minimally expressed elsewhere but now
since we had been screening for genes
that are specific for Crohn's disease if
we add other diseases I as I have added
here these are not all that we tested
it's just an example to illustrate it
but for example here in in these
inflammatory diseases we can see that
the genes found to be top regulated if
you do a differential expression in this
study were also regulated in quite a
number of other inflammatory diseases
whereas in our approach the genes we
found were specific for crohn's disease
they were not regulated in these other
inflammatory diseases either so it
allowed us to screen 14 that are really
specific for the disease of interest and
not involved in other things which makes
them much more interesting in a certain
way or attractive to be
as novel targets for the disease unless
you want to develop a drug that can be
applied to other inflammatory diseases
as well but if you want to do drug
discovery specific for one disease or
you want to study the mechanism of that
disease and understand the biology
it might be worth also looking at the
approach that we propose here where you
find genes really specific for the
disease of interest and there are also
other diseases here cancers and I did
not include the different drug responses
here but except for
infliximab Andra Delma but otherwise I
did not include them but they are also
interesting effects as you can see there
where the kids we found to be best
scoring were actually not changing very
much in any of those other conditions
but the genes that you find looking in a
very focused individual way of disease
versus healthy in one single study I did
not allow to screen against that now if
we take these genes that were found in
two or four studies or three or four
studies and we look at their expression
in different tissues what you see here
is the next part of the tissue level
expression of these 21 tunes and 14
genes that we saw before across more
than 400 different tissue and cell types
and these are figures done with clear
indicator what you can see here is that
these genes are sometimes specific for
particular tissues like the ones here on
the right of the first figure but you
can see also genes that are expressed in
many many different tissues if you
compare that to the third figure you can
see here this figure here where we
perform the global search of crohn's
disease against all the other diseases
what is interesting is that these genes
found were all expressed in tissues that
were very relevant
for the disease so they had a very
strong expression in colonic bukoza
in also the small intestine pancreatic
duct the contract even a telepathy Liam
but especially also in extracted columns
of mucosal cells and pancreatic islet
cells and also here alveolar sac cells
so these are all cells with some
epithelial structures and the the genes
that we found to be very specific for
Crohn's disease had a very strong and
much more specific expression in those
tissues that are relevant for our
disease then in any of the other tissues
and you would see the case here in in
the other diseases here where you have
expression in all kinds of different
issues as well so it was a nice
confirmation for us that the approach we
followed not only allowed to find genes
that are specific for the disease but
also that we saw they were expressed
nicely in tissues that are relevant for
the disease so in summary the approach
that we propose here to the community is
on the one hand a single experiment
analysis where you compare a treatment
and the control or a disease versus
healthy and where you do collection wide
analysis or platform wide analysis where
you assemble data from hundreds or
thousands of different conditions and
then you screen for genes that are
specific and in the first case it's a
very useful approach we don't want to to
in any way discredit this approach but
it doesn't answer quite the same
question as the one we were trying to
answer so in the first case you are
looking at leads that will be regulated
in response to the disease without
having information about how they are
regulated in response to other diseases
but did you know that they are somehow
related to your disease of interest and
that is already very important
piece of information whereas in our case
we were interested to know which are
those exclusively expressed or if it's
not possible of course the biology may
not allow it to be excluded expressed
they might be related to uses but at
least you will find those genes that are
as specific as possible to your disease
of interest and this has maybe different
types of applications than the first
type of let's say traditional different
expression in this case here it is very
useful too for the identification of
biomarkers or to identify novel targets
that could be used to to treat disease
or if you are studying the biology of
the disease you will come across new
genes that you may not have seen before
because these genes that come up as
disease specific are not always those
that are the most strongly regulated in
terms of voltage or intensity but they
are simply expressed or regulated there
but not elsewhere and that's why
frequently they drop out of the analysis
if you do it in a disease versus healthy
way on single experiments because they
are sometimes not very strongly
regulated but that's not what we are
scouring for we are scouring here for
specificity and that's why we get only a
partial overlap with the results that
you get in let's say traditional
differential expression analysis so the
conclusion is that the differential
expression analysis as we traditionally
do it where we compare one group of
disease versus the healthy controls
allows to find in these related genes
and for the example we chose the overlap
was actually even very low which was
quite surprising but that's that's a
fact and only a small proportion of
these
these related genes were
disease-specific as we could see in the
slide here the overlap between disease
related and disease specific was
relatively small there were five or six
genes here which were also found using
traditional differential expression but
were found if we did scoring against all
other diseases but it's only small
proportion all the others were change
that were also regulated in other
conditions if we did differential
expression on one study at a time so the
completely wide search to find is
regulated in a chosen disease versus
minimal expression in other diseases
allowed us to find disease specific
genes much more efficiently but it's not
something that it's a weaselly done
because you have to assemble all of the
datasets you have to prepare them to be
normalized in the same way that they can
be compared and analyzed all together
and that's why we developed the tool
that allows our users to do exactly this
type of analysis so I hope we have been
able to show a little bit the work we
have been on in the past years to allow
this type of analysis and if you are
interested to to to run such analysis
you are welcome to contact me or through
our website and we can help you getting
this done for your disease of interest I
would like to acknowledge different
organizations who have been working with
us in the past years first of all eth
zurich which is the parent University
from which our spin-off has started the
Swiss Commission for technology and
innovation a venture kick and of course
our software developers developers and
bio curators who have reached done a
great job of assembling all of the data
and making tools for our scientists to
be able to analyze all of these datasets
and run new types of queries and I would
like to thank all of you for joining
this
and I'm welcome to take questions Thank
You dr. Zimmerman for that informative
presentation we will now starts a live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question that you would like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we can let's get
started our first question is why do you
think the results from the different
Crohn's disease studies don't overlap
well so I think personally that as I
showed in this slide that probably the
main reason is that the collection of
the different biopsies which is not done
in the same way in the different
laboratories where some will be
collecting adjacent issues or the
proportions of the different cell types
is different and this is something which
we have been thinking a lot about
because it causes big biases in the
differential expression analysis in many
studies and we are currently working on
methodology to be able to standardize
the differences in cell type
compositions so that we can fish out
much more specifically the genes that
are really caused by the disease and
those that may be caused by differences
in composition
Thank You dr. ximena for our next
question we have why do we need the
entire data set for all diseases to find
genes specifically regulated in a single
disease would it be enough to compile
the list of regulated genes for each
disease and then search for genes that
are found exclusively in the list from
the disease of interest yes that's a
good point there have been different
approaches published to date where
called meta-analysis where you collect
results that have been produced in
different studies looking at the same
disease process and you may collect
let's say a few hundred genes for every
one of these studies as we did for
Crohn's disease and then you start
looking at what overlaps between the
different studies there are methods that
go with beyond that where you can
assemble all the gene expression
measurements for all of these contrasts
and then you run a meta-analysis on it
to find genes that are significantly
regulated so not only looking at
overlaps of lists but really doing
statistics on on this subset of studies
but in that case as well you are still
looking only that what happens in
Crohn's disease versus controls or in
any other disease versus the controls
and what we wanted in our case will not
to focus only on one disease but to be
able to answer the question which genes
are specific for my disease as compared
to any other disease so that we can get
a graph of what's really happening in
that party
disease and what could be the cause of
that disease or where could there be a
point of intervention specific for that
disease which we we now know that it is
it is nothing more than anything else
and it is something new so that's the
reason why we need all the measurements
for all the genes and not only the
results that are collected from
different studies and doing an
enrichment sort of analysis but we need
to be able to screen globally for all
the genes and then get out the best ones
creator okay it looks like we have one
more question for now a disease can be
manifested in different tissues how do
you define disease specific in such a
case yes this is a physical question
frequently we when we talk together as
scientists we don't really talk
precisely we say things like I'm working
on genes that are related to a
particular disease and somebody else
might be working on the same disease but
on another tissue type for example on
blood samples whereas the other are
working on the disease organ the third
one may be working only on a sub portion
of the blood like on immune cells and so
on and each of them will be in his or
her mindset will be thinking that they
are working on the genes that are
involved in the disease but if you would
compare what happens in the different
processes there might be completely
different and so the list of genes they
are working with will be completely
different so it's true that I think
scientists
we need to be a bit more aware of the
context around which we are working in
may be formulated a little bit more
precisely that if we are working on a
disease organ for example here will
cause us issues of the column we can say
we are working on genes involved in the
disease on a particular tissue type but
they may be different than the person
working on a diagnostic to identify
markers for the disease in body fluids
which which may be a completely
different process I think it's a it's a
lot of question question about how
precisely we formulate the question of
disease genes so yeah I think we should
be careful not to just generalize and
say I'm Dino the disease genes for that
disease but we should always put the
context to it
in particular the tissue or cell type
context on which one is working I would
like to once again thank dr. Zimmerman
for his presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August of 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye